Slovakia will stop sending military aid to Ukraine,
the country's new prime minister,
Robert Fitzow
has announced,
following through on a promise he made
during the recent election campaign.
Before Fitzow took office on October the 25th,
Slovakia had been one of Ukraine's
staunchers supporters,
supplying the neighbouring country with an air
defense system,
fighter jets
and lots more.
The Kramlin has reacted to the change in policy by
downplaying its impact,
saying overall that Slovakia provided
only a small fraction of total military aid to Ukraine.
So, who is now beginning his third
non consecutive stint as prime minister,
has suggested that he wants to focus on humanitarian
and civilian aid instead.
Speaking ahead of an EU leader summit,
he also said he will oppose
whose new European sanctions on Russia
if he judges them to harm Slovakia.
He also repeated his opposition to Ukraine joining NATO
and said he didn't think that the country
was ready to join the EU,
though suggested that he wouldn't block
the opening of accession negotiations.